so hello everybody I'm here with JP Matt
so some of you might have seen him on my
channel you might have seen discussions
between him and John for Becky he also
has a YouTube channel where he talks
about the relationship between symbolism
and emergence and pent psychism all
these really fascinating things one of
the greatest thing that's been going on
in the past few months were those who
haven't been following is that we
started a symbolic world blog and JP is
the main editor the chief editor of the
blog he's managing all the writers and
deciding which articles are going online
and everything so I've been really happy
to partner with him and I've been very
excited about the the quality of the
article that I've been coming up and in
this discussion we're going to look at
his ideas related to the symbolic
thinking and also the two articles that
he put up on the symbolic world blah
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so JP to start maybe you can tell people
how your experience has been we've been
we started I think we launched about a
month ago or maybe a bit more what has
been your experience in terms of
managing the blog and seeing these
articles pop up from our different
collaborators yeah it's been great to be
able to have a correspondence have a
back and forth with different symbolic
thinkers so of course initially it was
like sitting people up sending emails
gathering people and then once of the
workflow got started it's been fun I've
learned a lot already some people as you
said I've been writing excellent
articles and it's worth mentioning that
you got those people initially from the
the Facebook group so I don't this the I
think it's the symbolic world within
their zombie invasion that's right all
right that's run by our friend right
Russell yes right yeah and it's been a
good community to be a part of it's been
cool to see the quality of the posters
have been coming up and by dee dee yeah
just improvements in the level of
symbolic thinking that I've seen around
it's crazy if I think oh let's see three
years ago four years ago when you
started making videos Jonathan and
people were sort of interested in you
but they didn't know what you were
really talking about and now not only
are people understanding but they can
even contribute themselves so this if I
look at it at the long term I find it
all very exciting and then yeah alright
that's really it's not it's strange cuz
that's been one of the most exciting
things for me is to really watch this
kind of crew come up you know very
fascinating obviously good intuition and
a good capacity to kind of take people
through the steps you know of their
symbolic thinking applying it to all
kinds of things that I wouldn't have
thought of and also pulling in strains
in terms of analogies from different
traditions that I don't really know that
well know people people obviously have
their own baggage and their own
knowledge you know their own line from
which they pull their ideas and that's
why I was really happy to see the first
article you put up I put up the very
very first article kind of introducing
people and then your article came up
strong right away
a because I'm not really a formal
philosophical thinker I I'm more
intuitive more analogical I use images
and stories so I'm more let's say taking
it from the artistic perspective whereas
you are really able to write an article
which trace the line between the
symbolic thinking that we're trying to
develop you know the new the Platonic
thinking Aristotelian thinking all the
way to Thomas Aquinas and then
connecting it also with new ideas of
emergence so maybe you can give us a
little bit of idea a little bit of an
idea of your article that so that we can
talk about that yeah yeah sure I can
treat it part of thinking in this
article to the several conversations
I've had with John Ricky because it's
really the course of those discussions
that became obvious when when talking to
him and also by reading the comments and
interacting with other people who had
watch the videos that you can start with
a like the the bleeding edge of
scientific thinking you can start with
commit a sign that is starting that is
trying to together the different
ontological levels within science and
yeah their field get from there fairly
smoothly to symbolic thinking to the
sort of worldview that you founded the
neoplatonist for example so I can try to
lay it out very quickly what has been
happening is
well like drink that the Renaissance
progressively people tried to reduce
everything down to the material level
because people were able to calculate
things and it was yelling more and more
progress over time so people get
progressively more materialistic but
it's been sort of blowing up in the last
few decades on if you in a few different
Sciences actually and the sir I don't
want to take like a very long time and
spell out the different places where it
drove down exactly and what are the
precise solutions that people give to
the different levels but the bottom line
is that something that integrates all of
those new yeah those new facts within
science is the basic I knew picnic idea
that the world is made of potential and
patterns so you can see it at every
level within the scientific ontology you
can start just right away from from the
bottom at the bottom of physics what
looks like is there at people quibble
about the details and there is lots of
disagreements between physicists trying
to interpret what this what this could
all mean but a common interpretation and
one that will work well when we apply to
other levels of being as well is to see
the ground layer of physics as just
potential feel the potential from which
different particles can emerge so you
have the idea you can have particles
that emerge from potential and then once
those particles are there they will
emerge also the potential that's below
them they will they won't influence what
other particles can can emerge they will
influence the interactions between those
different particles and then if you take
a set of of particles you can also see
how their potential for iron level atoms
or molecules so of course a a molecule
for instance is made of several atoms
and particles and in one sense you can
see the molecule as emerging from those
but you can also see that the the
molecule isn't forming the potential
that is below it it's out of all of the
things that could happen with those
different particles
there is a something very precise that
actually occurs is the pattern of this
molecule and then you can keep going up
the levels of being in a a cell for
instance you have tons of enzymes you
have different molecules that could be
doing several different things all over
the place they could go the cell could
eat that yourself it could fragment it
could do a bunch of stuff but all it
from all this potential all of the
different stuff that exists at the level
of the molecules within the cell what
actually happens is a the emergence of a
global pattern of the pattern of the
cell which will then in turn inform what
happens with those different molecules
and then we could go I oh I are up to
the human level where we see this within
our own being and this has been
committed especially in cognitive
science as people try to study the mind
that how it is that our cognition work
take all of the possibilities that I
have within my body within my members
just even if I just take one of my
members I just take my eyes and the way
I look at the screen and I see you
Jonathan right now I could be focusing
on a myriad of different things but I
will actually gather only a few most
significant points in there like your
eyes like maybe a your your eyebrows a
bit of your mouth and so on and I will
so power gather from all of this
potential from all this potential that
at the level of my CD the photons
hitting my out my eyeballs
there's tons of financial information I
could focus on right there I will
constrain that potential into a simpler
pattern of just eyes and and eyebrows
and face and so on so I take very
complex information very complex
potential i condense it into a higher
level pattern and in turn then that I a
little pattern will influence what I
will do also in the future with the
potential that isn't my body so out of
all these things that I could say with
my mouth out of all the complex
interactions that you learn with my
cells in my mouth or in my lungs this
one I will say these very precise words
so you have we started from the very
layer very bottom layer of physics of
just killed the potential being gutter
with you saying that from those
fundamental fields there emerge
particles and then those particles
become matter they become potential for
the the atoms the atoms become potential
for sales for humans and we can keep
going i europe as well we can take the
example of a one i really like is the
church for instance or not even before
go to the church we can go to it family
let's see in a tradition do stick try
and take your family like jonathan is
the head of his family and you can see
this in the way that you will gather
from all the potential things that is
family could you so that the different
members will be doing the family so I'm
going to be reading over there someone
could be carving over there sometimes
Jonathan will act in a way that will
gather all of these potential
interactions from the family and you
will have them do a precise thing let's
see maybe eat or maybe a go to church
and so on so you'll gather this
potential into one pattern of the family
to D D actions the family
at the ire pattern of Leslie going to
church or or or eating at a certain
amount of the day and so on so you have
an emergence from different individuals
the emergence of a a pattern the pattern
of a family that goes through you
Jonathan
and then that falls back down into the
process things that that you do so you
have you can sit as emergence from the
potentialities in your family of a
pattern a more abstract or a ire level
phenomenon and then this one from this
will emanate also constraints on those
individuals and you can see the same
thing of it and going on in a church
where the priest goes does the same
things that you do in your family I'll
be gathering all the people and then if
you go even higher up you can see Christ
doing this also with the whole of
creation really he is served in the is
little story
that will contain and gather all of the
other stories so we all had different
stories in our different parishes
there's all sorts of stuff going on but
out of all of this potential tress
gathered it all into one abstract
pattern and then it's this pattern has
also been unfolding throughout history
in us so yeah you want to say something
no I was just going to say that what
definitely is fascinating is how similar
and if you use terms like emergence and
you talk about potentiality and the way
that you did you know it I think that
most physicalist will understand what
you're talking about least physicalist
that have been attempted to the problem
of emergence but you know for anybody
who is knows a little bit of classical
thinking you right away recognize that a
notion in Aristotle for example of
matter you know and and then because
when he was talking about matter he
wasn't talking about matter the way we
talked about it but he was talking about
matter at every level on to the
different potential if these yes right
so potentiality and in any level on the
on the hierarchy of being is is matter
for the name or the identity that is
above which is which is forming it yeah
and we people are starting to take those
are little patterns more and more
seriously and that's that for a lot of
people were just trying to reduce
everything down to the bare minimum
layer just try
to reduce everything down to matter but
it it it costs a bunch of problems like
you couldn't really take even just
biology seriously the apology supposed
to be science and we can actually do
real things with it but it if it was
somehow reduced to to matter it was
causing problems in philosophy of
science for because we always use
theological Tildy illogical words when
talking about about biology and you need
real potential for even just evolution
to make sense like there has to be real
potential for for genetic variation
otherwise biology becomes sort of a a
chimera became just an illusion and it
also blows up at the human level because
we do see patterns in our minds at least
but it's it's really people still try
some people still try to reduce the mind
to something like matter and try to say
or say that the mind doesn't exist but
it's it's a minority position by now
most people will do something that they
call a non reductive physicalism or a
weak emergence where it's got eyes I got
exactly what I mentioned where there is
potential in our body in our bodies and
somehow all this potential is gathered
in a special member in our head and
there are higher level patterns there
which you can find if you were to just
look at our individual cells like the
fact that Jonathan gets up in the
morning and typically goes carving is
it's not a matter that you'll find
individual cells in your body it's a
pattern that exists at the emergent
level of the organization between all of
your cells and in that emerging pattern
somehow there is consciousness with
perceptions which with choices with
emotions and so on and without even
having to spell out the precise relation
between mind and body people will
largely agree that okay but at least at
least there is such a thing as like your
ed mediating some out between your
matter and your mind we don't have to be
precise there is a there is a an
invisible pattern you know even though
they might try to find ways to get
around talking about it or use the word
information for example who is it that I
heard one of the new atheist types who
said that oh well at least now we now we
know that basically the world is made of
matter and information I was like okay
mr. new platonic atheist like let's keep
talking from
from from that point on interesting
stuff yeah and then we can link that up
to symbolism because symbolism is
believed the study of how you jump from
those different layers of being like
what are the symbols that connect levels
of being together and in that article I
I especially used add body symbolism
that's we have been already a link to it
in my explanation yeah it's the kind of
symbolism I I tend to use most like and
as you said it's it's a joy in the blog
really that different people will tend
to use different kinds of symbolism like
their Eugene wheeler likes to use
animals or dragons and beasts and so on
there's a I think max really likes to
use like space and time you'd like to
use Center in periphery I like to use
head and body and it's you can see st.
Paul doing this where and it's it's not
a it's not it's not really a surprise
considering that st. Paul was both a Jew
coming from a symbolic background and
also really a wellness studied yeah was
a Roman was the leading in Greek yeah
philosophy so you can see in putting
those two together when he uses the ED
body symbolism to describe the
relationship between not only with our
individual elves with Ed's with our
bodies but also the relationship between
the the Father and the Sammy and also
the relationship between Christ and the
church
hmm so it's been it's it's what I tried
to lay out in in that article yeah when
I like about the article especially is
you you really take the time to kind of
show the process and so like I I tend to
work by when I'm talking about symbolism
I'd I tend to work by analogy and
surprise it's like I'm going to create
an analogy and then you're going to be
surprised to see your intuition kind of
wake up but what I love about your
article is that you actually show the
levels it's like okay from this like
just like you did now you you you really
showed how the necessity of this pattern
to manifest itself from the scientific
sense you know in terms of atoms and
molecules and bodies but then also in
terms of stories in terms of your day
in terms of anything which has form
anything which presents itself to us as
existing we'll have to participate in
this pattern of emergence and well with
interest I love I actually I find the
word emergent to larious I tend to find
it very funny because it's it really is
I feel like it's this like last last
ditch like fist you know saying okay
okay I see this is this is real but I'm
still gonna do it bottom-up like I I
don't want to accept that there's also
like order coming back down to form the
yeah and I think that's why I like so
much to not only start from let's say
our bodies and then use that at body
symbolism to go to the other levels
being I like to also go down and see
that it works even lower because
something that will be very convincing
to physicalist or scientific types like
if I can show that the same I can think
of myself when I used to be a
physicalist like I could understand well
how you go from let's say particles to
atoms molecules to cells and if I can
reuse that machinery that the
physicalist uses that's it to think
about the relationship between the
nucleus in a cell and the organelles in
the cell I can use that to have him
think about himself in terms of his head
in his body and then about Christ in the
church like I used is no is less this
she attempted to reduce everything to
the physical and turned it into
something that can add spiritual
significance and it's I really like the
example of the the nucleus in the inner
cell because you know if you take the
nucleus it's a it's an organ unlike the
other organs in the cell like a
mitochondria and all of the other stuff
but it will gather all of what occurs in
those different organs into himself and
somehow it will turn it into meaningful
information but it will say that okay
well these various enzymes that are
coming from this organ when the nucleus
it will like have these extremely
complex interactions with DNA and at the
iron level you see this as an exchange
of information of genetic information
and you just get away from
this language within just biology itself
so you use this information and the cell
will want to do this or do that
so it will then order your guns to
create this enzyme or this enzyme in
response so you can see like the
different parts of the different members
of the cell being gathered in their head
gathered in the other the nucleus yes
will like race to higher level patterns
and then bring it back down to incarnate
in the cell and the same thing that
happens in our in our bodies same thing
that happens in a community in a rare
instance where you air everyone has
their different inducing crises their
different patterns that are clear to
them within the day and then they will
talk with one another and they will also
talk with the priest they will go to
confession they will tell the tell him
about the the best parts of their day or
the worst part of the days and the
priest will gather all of this up and
then you will try to make it all fit
within the story of the Incarnation so
it takes all those individual stories
brings it into the is story and then
uses also is symbolic skills to bring it
back down to the people either by
talking to them by altering the prayers
during Mass or by creating different
prayer groups around the church and so
on so you can see the same the same sort
of pattern that is occurring within
cells is opening is occurring within us
and it's occurring within the church as
well yeah and it's occurring you know if
you get the idea of a leader or the idea
of a king or something like that or a
president you can see that having
because like you said the the king or
the president is just a person like he's
the season of the same stuff as all the
other people in his group yeah but
because he has a cuz he has he's been
anointed or he has a crown or he's been
chosen it doesn't matter which word you
use then he ends up moving above
gathering the will of the people into
himself but also he also like you said
in forming the the will of the people to
a certain extent it's a managing and
doing all those words that we use so you
can see that like the idea that a cell
and a country has the same structure is
something which which on the one hand
can in a way I think maybe soothe the
physicalist to a certain extent because
we're saying this is it like this is
this not magical fairies in the way that
you think about it it's not although
fairies are part of it too but we'll get
the fairies in angels later but for now
you can understand that when we talk
about these spiritual truths which
inform reality it's it's the same thing
happening the sell that's happening in
the city and so it can help you
understand what we're talking about when
we talk about these things yeah and I
remember I in a conversation I had with
John and also America when we brought up
the idea of okay so because the sort of
metaphysics had just been putting forth
is like John likes this he thinks this
works quite well and we uh we asked him
whether within committed science this
was sort of widespread attitude or if it
if other people were more physically
sztyc and he said that it's it's sort of
shifting now and for now a lot of people
are still like reductionist physicalist
but he says that there's also I don't
really the statistics but like most
people who don't come from just a
technical background like people were
background let's say linguistics or
paucity will acknowledge the sort of
ontology that I just laid out so we
didn't even just science like the fact
that they're this sort of metaphysics is
soothing to them I think we can see I
the fact that like John and a bunch of
other cognitive scientists are willing
to endorse it hmm yeah that's great and
so the next thing I wanted to talk about
is really your last your last article
that you put up which is the symbolism
of cell tower burning just such a great
it's such a great timely article and
you're able to really bring break down
the the question of symbolism and its
relationship to intuition that people
have and how sometimes let's say you
don't necessarily the causality that
people think is there doesn't
necessarily have to be there for the
pattern to be true or the pattern to be
real so maybe you can give us a sense
people can check out the article for
sure and I think you also have a version
of it that you're reading online so
people can check it out but you can give
us a little hint of what you're talking
about and it'll be a good it'll be a
good example to kind of play through the
different levels that you talked about
in terms of cells and everything else
yeah I think it's a good thing
simplification for the
like that we with star symbolism and
that's we're not very good at it but if
we if we practice it let's say the other
blog or we are going to church or if we
practice and listen there's a bunch of
stuff there's a bunch of patterns that
are much more obvious to us
for instance I took the case of people
bearing down cellphone towers because
coming from me yeah from they just
explain it to people that what happened
during the pandemic so you don't know if
you're living in a cave of some so I'm
sorry for it first
during the pandemic they were because
there were certain people who were
saying that the virus was caused or made
worse by cell technology 5g technology
then they started to see this this kind
of cell technology as like a mass
conspiracy to control people and to to
also kill people off you know like to
reduce work populate or whatever like
all the conspiracy that came around it
and some people took it so far that they
went out and actually destroyed some
cell towers and so there you go now you
can explain the pattern that manifested
itself yeah because what happens is I
think people grasp don't like that they
are the symbolic intuition for real
patterns that occur at the psychological
and also sociological scale but because
we're not very good at detecting those
anymore or treating them as
psychological and social patterns people
try to bring down onto the material
matter metric level and that's what
caused issues so I can see what or I
think the the the valid patterns that
occur
at the psychological and social levels
so you can even just start biologically
like the fact that cell phone towers
allow people to communicate easily by
communicating easily with one another
I think internet all over the place you
can travel easily it's easy to do
business with other people so this inter
communication within the world allowed
people to like physically move easily
and to spread pathogens so at the
biological level there's at the zoo yeah
the social level there's already
something there relating cell phone
towers and the virus at a psychological
level there is the fact that there's
tons of stuff that had to do with
technology and how it made us more
inclined for the all of the panic that
we saw that the fact that we were we had
so much so much enjoyment possible at
her fingertips like via our cell phones
made people quite willing to just Punk
her down and stay in their homes to be
very obedient to the government the
government was also much more able to
monitor what was going on because
technology allows us to communicate so
easily like the research can can spread
the like what doctors in China can
influence what we do here and then also
the government can propagate information
quickly we can tell people okay now yet
follow this law in useful data and so on
you can even track people just with our
cell phones to see if they obey or not
those regulations and then you can also
add at the communal level as well that
we saw a huge social media panic and
this just adds fuel to the fire where
people feel really trapped by cell phone
towers like so you can see that there
are real patterns from the cell phone
towers that occur at the social and
cycle and psychological levels yeah
because such a huge part of the covert
thing and the lockdown was based on
media and information and like you said
our willingness to accept the lockdown
because I mean can you imagine just 30
years ago maybe you're you know 40 years
ago the idea that the government could
have imposed this so easily on everybody
would have just been
impossible you know the internet gave it
made it possible for people to work from
home made all these things possible
which made us accept the the statement
of the pandemic and you know and the
panic all of this together and so this
is that so the idea that that cell
technology was part and all even in a
way a cause of the situation was
absolutely true there's no way to deny
it
yeah it's really so if we can see the
cell tower as a is symbol because it's a
physical artifact it exists at the
physical level it's a real power made of
metal and plastics is one but it
mediates also with the psychological and
social levels because it participated in
the social patterns that fuel the COBE
crisis so I think conspiracy theorists
to blame the cell phone towers for the
virus or at least for part of the virus
will Intuit this tendency ballad
intuition to start up but rather than
seeing this as a properly social and
psychological phenomenon to which you
need to provide a psychological and
social answer they casted they cast it
down to the physical layer because
that's what we tend to do as we discuss
it's only been in the last few decades
that we've been starting to rediscover
like neoplatonism and those different
theories that incorporate potential and
form at different layers of being so
it's not surprising that people would
cast down the social problems that they
into it from this Nestle towers and that
they would cast them down into the
language of physics but this you can see
that okay and you can control yeah you
can contrast this with what happened
let's say to the Israelites because they
would do some things something similar
from time to time it would notice that
they there were something breaking out
their social and psychological patterns
like maybe the worshiping a golden
caffeine is causing all kinds of trouble
so it would get rid of that Golden Cap
but it's not the whole thing did we do
it wouldn't just like burn the cap down
and then hope that because they burn
they don't physically then all of a
sudden things will be okay
they also reinstated other practices
yeah gathered themselves together
so it's not just a physical problem it's
a it's a social problem you need a
social solution for it
but I think this is the step that the
the arsonists don't quite yet things
won't just get better because you burn
down this earth hours yeah exactly and
in terms of the imagery it's very
powerful because in Scripture there's a
there the they call the ash eras or the
sacred poles and so the there's several
moments in scripture where the
Israelites kind of give in to building
these sacred poles that are dedicated to
other gods and and then they destroy the
sacred poles so there's something about
the actual visual you talk about this in
your article as well the actual fact
that cell towers appear above us and you
see them as these towering things is
also part of the problem or part of the
reason why they end up attracting
attention in terms of the source of the
because they're their visible totem yeah
all of technology of all of media of all
of this kind of strange connectedness
that we have through through the
internet and also all the problems that
come with that all the social diseases
that are related to to to the Internet
and to this this type of connection and
so like you said in a kind of weird
intuitive way there's something that is
intuitively I'm not we're not at all
saying you should come or say that we
could understand the fact that people
would have that intuition that okay
here's here's an actual image of
something which is causing the problem
in our society yeah yeah I think well we
can even see I sort of entered at it in
my article what the the actual solution
would be to this as a as it's
psychological and social problem and not
as a material problem and one way of
seeing it is that by casting the problem
in terms of physics they're not able to
see all of the other sides of the social
patterns and they're not able to address
the problem correctly so no cell towers
also have a good social effects like the
fact that they can allow people to
communicate from overseas the fact that
they allow us to communicate now for
instance the fact that it it did allow
my experts to exchange information
quickly there's good side
- this this phenomenon and the the real
solution I think would have been obvious
in societies where symbolism was better
practice like it if you just consider
the fact that there are cities now where
the cellphone tower is higher than the
highest church tower right yeah and of
course like cell phone towers like they
get big they defragment people
physically they there is symbol of the
technology that fragments us physically
physically isolate us just like that
just like the people like the virus than
they're doing yeah and it's the opposite
from what the church used to do like the
ice point in villages that used to be
the church where people would gather
they would worship together and it
closed once so people would commune so
you can see we went from a place where
community we would gather around the
highest point which was the church now
the highest point is the cell phone
tower in the premises and the solution
is to well it's a a social solution at
the social level what we need to do is
we need to like build communities that
will built up that will build churches I
go higher than our cellphone towers like
that the social solution but there is no
like quick intervention you can do it's
like to do this you need to convert
people slowly and it's much more
tempting to just burn down the cell
towers and hope for the best but of
course it doesn't work yeah because you
have nothing to replace it with yeah and
it's interesting because on the flip
side of this like on the flip side of
people who want to destroy the cell
towers right when covent started to hit
and i remember here in Quebec which used
to be the most Catholic place in the
world but is now you know one of the
probably the most atheistic places in
the world on the radio unlike hit radio
okay sequa like the most hit radio like
that exists they spent they would they
kept going over and over how people
should not go to church and how people
who go to church should not use holy
water that you shouldn't go to communion
all of these things were vectors of
transmission and they were talking
solely about that on the radio and I was
like who are you talking to who are you
talking to cuz no one does that like
none of the people listening to your
radio station go to church or very few
of them and so I was like this is
interesting they're seeing that the
church is a place of communion and is it
still like late mythologically in their
background thinking yeah you know the
place of communion and so that's the
first place they attacked and when they
wanted to to socially separate so it was
just a very fascinating thing to notice
yeah
yeah that's interesting and to try to
bring it back to the blog I think it's
those sort of patterns that would have
been more obvious in more traditional
societies it's something that what we're
trying to like faster on the blog and in
this online community in general where
we're trying to practice seeing the
world this way we're trying to practice
seeing the different symbols that all
the different players have realty
together so that when something weird
occurs like that when social patterns
emerge that we can actually see them and
we don't just burn down the cell towers
or like fuel the the problem some other
way that we can actually diagnose the
issue and do something positive maybe
under it and a wavy little hiccup that
I'll notice I'll I'll mention just
because I think it's it's worth
mentioning that people should go on jp's
video about the cell tower burning and
notice that there is a comment by Matt
Apuzzo by my brother there and and he
reminds us that that even though we can
see all the symbolism in terms of story
in terms of social in terms of
psychological that it doesn't mean that
there isn't a hint of material causality
there and so you can go check that out
for yourself and there's strange things
happening in the scientific world as
well so go check that out
I'm really excited to see because I
noticed that the next article coming out
is something called the dragon of
Minneapolis yeah I'm really looking
forward to seeing how some of the people
on the blog are going to interpret
what's happening around us right now
yeah it's a good article I read it and
I'll probably post it on next Tuesday so
nice so making 40 cents the next article
I think yeah I'm trying to figure out
how much I'm gonna get into what's going
on right now I might do a video on feet
washing or something like that to try
to address some of the questions of the
things we've been seeing going on but
seems like the world is is just
spiraling into into madness faster and
faster the clown world was funny for a
while it just does it it's not as funny
anymore
it's looking more like a like a
diabolical clown with pointy teeth yeah
it's just scary now and there's too many
patterns like to untangle it's difficult
like it's Peters going very fast too
it's just because everything's speeding
up it's very difficult to kind of keep
up it's like but we're still taking
we're still like breathing in from kovat
and now mass riots everywhere in the US
and everything and soon an election in
the u.s. is going to take over in terms
of patterns because we're going to see
take sides and then we're gonna see some
interesting pattern there as well but
yeah so everybody buckle up for the rest
of 20 tonight we're not done yeah we're
gonna in symbolism for this because
there's too many like monsters that are
sort of mingling and interacting one
others it makes it better to diagnose
like there are definitely zombies in
those riots but there's also like other
kinds of monsters and I I haven't
wrapped my head around it yet like it's
I don't know if I have time to do it
before it's even over oh yeah it's it's
and it's interesting stuff so so yeah so
guys go go to the blog follow the blog
if you are someone who is really good at
is symbolic thinking come on the
Facebook group get your chops train your
train yourself to think symbolically so
that we can have a little army of
symbolic thinkers to to let's say hold
out the madness as the world spirals out
of control alright everybody thanks for
attention and JP thanks for your time as
usual I it's a good conversation thank
Jonathan all right
I hope you enjoyed this discussion on
emergence and the symbolism of cell
tower burning as you heard here in this
interview there's a lot of stuff going
on around the symbolic world around this
symbolic thinking we have the website
and the articles and the blog that we
talked about with JP all of these videos
are also being put out as a podcast
called the symbolic world there is also
a clips channel which is constantly
putting out material by subject and so
if you always if you ever wondered what
I think about this or that that is
definitely the place to look they're
doing a great job and of course if you
enjoy what we're doing we are doing this
completely through the help of people
who are financing us who are funding us
who are supporting us and so go check
out my web site at the support page and
see the different wage within which you
can support this adventure for those who
support the podcast I have a monthly
free video and this month it will
probably be a video on the symbolism of
foot washing and it will be related to
kind of the some of the madness that
we've seen around the world in the past
few weeks so thanks your support
everybody and I will see you very soon